hi this is presh talwalkar
in this video i'm going to teach you a
really cool mental math trick of how you
can multiply any two numbers that end in
the digit five
i'll explain this process with several
examples and then i'll show you how you
can use it to solve many related
mathematical problems
at the end of the video i'll give you a
proof of why this method works
let's say you want to multiply 15 by 35
both the numbers 15 and 35
have a last digit of five
so there's a quick way we can solve this
the steps are to add the product and
average of the leading digits of the
number
we multiply that result by a hundred
and then we add 25
so let me go over these steps in detail
the numbers 15 and 35 both end in the
digit 5.
for the rest of the calculation we can
ignore these digits of 5 and focus on
just the leading digits of the number
the first step is to add the product and
the average of these digits
we find the product by multiplying one
by three to get three and we find the
average by taking the average of one and
three which is two
so we add the product of three to the
average of two to get five
and that's the hard part of the
computation the rest of it will be easy
we multiply this by a hundred to get
five hundred
and finally we add twenty five
we get the result of five hundred and
twenty five
and that's our answer fifteen times
thirty five is five hundred and twenty
five
let's do another example of this
technique
let's say you want to multiply 65 by 75
both of these numbers end in the digit 5
so we can cover up the digit 5.
we now want to multiply these digits to
get 42 and we take the average which is
6.5
adding this together we get 48.5
now we multiply by 100 to get 48.50
and then we add 25.
so we have 48.75
and that's our answer 65 by 75 is 48.75
you can also do this for digits for
numbers which have more than two digits
let's say you want to do 35 by a hundred
and fifteen
both of these numbers end in the digit
five
so we cover up the five and we only need
to do calculation for the leading digits
the product of three and eleven is
thirty three
the average of three and eleven is seven
adding these together we get forty
we then multiply by a hundred and
finally we add twenty five
this gets a result of four thousand
twenty five and that's the answer of
thirty five times a hundred and fifteen
so you can actually use this technique
to solve other problems let's say you
wanted to fill 14 gallons of gas at 3.18
cents
that would be the problem 14 times 3.18
now you can't use the technique because
neither of these numbers end in five
but you can estimate by considering a
related problem
what if you wanted to fill 15 gallons at
315 cents per gallon
that would be the problem of 15 times
315
so now both of these numbers end in the
digit 5 so we can use the technique that
we just learned in this video
we cover up the 5
then we take the product of 1 and 31
which is 31
we take the average which is 16
we add these together
and then we multiply by a hundred and
add 25.
so we get that 15 times 315 is
47.25
if we convert this back into dollars we
get 15 times 3.15 is 47.25
now we only wanted to fit this is to
estimate filling 15 gallons but of
course we only need to fill 14 gallons
so if we wanted to fill one fewer gallon
we would be multiplying 14 by 315.
so we subtract 315 from 47.25
so we subtract three dollars we get to
44 then we subtract 15 cents and then we
get 10 cents
so we figured out that 14 times 315 is
4410
and this is extraordinarily close
we wanted to solve 14 by 318
and that's 4452.
so using this process of multiplying two
numbers ending in five and doing a
slight modification we actually were
able to get within 42 cents of the exact
answer and we could do this all in our
head
so why does this technique work
if you're multiplying two numbers that
end in five that's multiplying the
binomials 10x plus five times 10y plus
five the x and y are the leading digits
of the number
if we expand this out we get a hundred
xy plus fifty times x plus y plus twenty
five
now fifty is one half of a hundred
so we can factor out a hundred and then
we get a hundred xy
plus the average of x plus y
and finally we add on 25 at the end
and this is the formula we've been using
in this video
x y is the product
x plus y over two is the average
so this is adding the product and
average of the leading digits
we're then multiplying by a hundred
that's the hundred part and then finally
we're adding 25.
if you like this video please check out
my book the best mental math trick
it includes techniques like this
complete with applications and examples
and mathematical proofs of why they work
there's a link in the video description
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my channel
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon
you can also catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker
and you can check out all my books there
are descriptions in the video
description